hey you guys movie retrospective time
we're doing some uh david lynch but this
is some david lynch that you actually
like tom yeah
this is like the first
and last david lynch movie that i
understood
i can understand this one a lot of that
what the [ __ ] we were watching what was
that one lost highway yeah i liked to
had good music had [ __ ] david bowie
in there ramstein in the background i
couldn't understand all it to me that
movie was about
that movie was about uh [ __ ] what's
what was that chick's name [ __ ]
picture yeah that was about patricia
arquette's boobs that's what that movie
was about that's about your love yeah
it's a movie about she even said that
while we were watching it because uh
yeah i did a flickers of fear i did a
review for it it's going up either like
not this week but i think like sometime
next week like next saturday or
something uh but yeah i did a review of
it and we were watching it and he was
kind of like watching it too and he's
just like this is like patricia
arquette's boobs the movie yeah
so yeah i thought it was like pretty
straightforward though
she was yeah yeah i had forgotten yeah i
had forgotten actually i'd forgotten how
good that movie was her in that movie
true romance
i love that that's another one we got to
see
we need to do a thing but yeah so uh
interestingly the elephant man
i honestly sometimes i don't know if i
forget that it's directed by david lynch
but if you watched it not knowing that
it was directed by david lynch you might
not know because it doesn't have
a lot of the lynchian kind of troops
although if you knew a lot about david
lynch's you know film catalog you would
recognize some lynchian as particularly
the sound design is very lynchian and um
also the way like particularly like the
the beginning sequence and the end
sequence which are kind of like
dream sequences not so much dreams but
like um inside the elephant man's mind
like you know it means they're kind of
like symbolic i guess they're sort of
dream sequences those are very david
lynchian but the rest of it is fairly
straightforward
um it does kind of tie in with a lot of
david lynch's kind of themes but i guess
because it was like a biographical
uh story you know based on a real guy
and
so and also this is really interesting
too because this is this is david
lynch's um it's only his second major
movie after eraserhead
so this is kind of like the first big
movie that he did
it's really interesting now because it's
kind of like look he made a racer head
which is weird as [ __ ] right that was
nice i understood that yeah that one's
yeah i think that one's kind of
straightforward too yeah he made that
one in 1977 which was like a huge like
midnight movie kind of hit like a huge
cult hit
um but at that point that was kind of
all he had made and at that point like
the studio system was kind of like hey
like this guy's kind of already farty
but we could still like give him like a
prestige project like the elephant man
um and you know he could really run with
that and actually this movie was really
successful but then that kind of led on
to them giving him dune and we all know
how that went i think it went well well
it's from a commercial standpoint
i mean the elephant man was a massive
massive success but it's crazy to think
that david lynch was very young and it's
like i was watching i was looking at
like the stills uh like the production
stills like from the making of this
movie and i was like oh my god he looked
like a baby like he looked so so young i
grew up seeing this movie on [ __ ]
cable this movie oh this movie is so
good it's so good this this should give
you a [ __ ] lump in your throat when
you're killed so sad though
it's a great movie it's a good movie
very very watchable real interesting
it's very conventional as far as lynch
goes it has a plot line it's telling a
cohesive narrative
it's got imagery and [ __ ] in it yeah
it's got like some weird lynchian
touches to it but it's really good now
dude i liked dune also
you know some people say dude was a
failure
the the failure was really with the
studio
you can't fit dune into one movie well
yeah we've talked about that yeah
that needs to be like a trilogy of
movies and so it's just kind of an
impossible task but he did real well it
did real good with what he got
yeah i thought i mean i think it's a
cool looking yeah but okay so the thing
about the elephant man this is kind of
crazy to me if you know anything about
like kind of film history if you know
anything about david lynch um he kind of
owes a lot of his
uh i don't want to say notoriety but his
like success i suppose to mel brooks
because
honestly he got what he had done a razor
head which like i said was a huge cult
hit
and
you know he was looking for another
project to do
and mel brooks wanted to do like he had
his own production company and he was
wanting to do uh the script of the
elephant man which is based on you know
the real guy and there had been like a
stage play about it too which they
actually which is a lot different they
wanted to kind of like um you know
distance themselves from that
but he'd been wanting to make that and
somebody recommended they're like oh hey
there's this you know hot new director
david lynch and mel brooks is like oh i
haven't heard of him and so they set up
a scheduling for mel brooks to see
eraser head and he saw a racer head and
he loved it and he's like oh yeah we're
giving this guy elephant man so i didn't
know brooks was into that kind of [ __ ]
yeah
and honestly uh mel brooks was a
producer on this but he left his name
off it because he's like i don't want
people thinking it's a comedy yeah
because that's what he yeah he's so
brook so that had that in him yeah okay
he had yeah he had his own production
company he was super into this kind of
stuff and he helped out like a lot of
young directors and uh stuff like that
like i said everybody knows him for like
you know blazing saddles and young
frank's like all his like parody kind of
stuff i've always heard that everybody
liked him yeah that's what i heard too
like he seemed like a really likable
dude yeah and he was a party dude you
know well yeah he was partying with that
[ __ ] blow
yeah he was known for blue weren't they
all about he was great envelope
his best brook's best movies were under
the influence of cocaine the cocaine
movie that's kind of true of a lot of
people like a lot of artistic people
sorry although you know cocaine or
heroine depending on what kind of like
format you're talking about in brook in
brooks's defense though he was very
talented it could have been
his his youth or he was at the right age
to where you produce some really cool
[ __ ] if you got money the cocaine might
have just been a side effect
yeah it's kind of hard money it's not
yeah and you know and it was hitting it
was all happening at the right time so i
don't i'm not going to say that cocaine
makes you make good movies it doesn't
well yeah you can make a good move you
give cocaine to some talentless hack
you're just gonna get like talentless
like shitty movies at like a faster
speed i guess he was making good movies
and he had cocaine and he was [ __ ]
having a good time yeah like i said i
don't i don't think i think you have to
have the talent to begin with the drugs
don't give you talent yeah but yeah so
so mel brooks was once he saw a racer
head he was very enthusiastically yes we
were putting the elephant man in david
lynch's hands and even though david
lynch was gonna be working on one of his
own script he was kind of like oh okay
so he really wanted to do it and it's
really um it's interesting too because
like i said david lynch is very young
he'd only done a racer head suddenly
he's on a set in the uk
with
john hurt sir john gielgud and bancroft
like all these really big like famous
british actors
and they said that at first like david
lynch seemed a little aloof but they
said actually he was just like really
kind of shy because
suddenly he's working with all of these
well-known british actors you know
anthony hopkins and all this other stuff
and so maybe he was i don't know if he
was like intimidated necessarily because
some of the actors said that he seemed
like you know confident like he knew
what he was doing but you can imagine
what that must be like for a young
director suddenly like thrust into this
milieu of like all these like really big
famous like and maybe being a little
intimidated so i could get that
but yeah so if you haven't seen it like
i said this is i love that he shot it in
black and white
i love that the way it's edited uh andy
coates was the editor i think she worked
with him uh on several other movies the
way it's edited
um evokes
old hollywood like a lot of the it's
almost kind of like even though it came
out in 1980 you would never know that
um it honestly it it plays it's timeless
it plays like a movie from the 1940s
which i think gives it like a really
timeless quality to it like you said in
i think also it evokes kind of like the
universal monster movies because even
though this is based on a real guy's
life and it's like a sad it's a very
tragic story
it's almost kind of like
you can kind of relate it to some of the
old quote unquote monster with the heart
movies kind of like king kong or like
you know uh hunchback of notre dame or
something like that so i think he was
kind of trying to evoke that sort of
timeless old horror movie yeah
quality i agree but not as wooden
yeah the oldest of the kind of wooden
and dated the stat the way things were
shot
were not that good in in the old class
some of it was depends on the movie this
thing shot really well god it's
beautiful more like a racer head yeah in
some ways but like yeah but i see what
you're talking about in terms of like
the universal monster movie yeah
like i said it's not exactly like that
but you can tell that that's what they
were trying that's what he was trying to
avoid it's a little more fluid a little
more updated i i think yeah and honest
and it's and it's
i don't want to say because a lot of the
movies from that era were kind of like
stagey because that's kind of like what
you were used to seeing yeah this one
has a little bit of that just like a
british stage actor type of thing but it
is a lot more cinematic i guess i always
you know the impression i always got
from this movie and i like i said i've
watched it many many times since i was a
kid
i took this movie very seriously as a
kid
there's something about the way the
movie comes across to you that this that
you're being told a factual story this
is some [ __ ] that really happened
i mean it did they they did like move
some facts around
it's fairly accurate yeah that doesn't
really
but they're whether it's real or not
doesn't matter it gives you the feeling
that it's real yeah that you're seeing
some real historical [ __ ]
and and that that helps you
get [ __ ] choked up about this movie
well it really immerses you in that
world yeah it pulls you in there
and the fact that they tried like i said
they did take some artistic liberties
with the story of joseph merrick the
real elephant man
um
but not as many as you might think i
mean they did actually try to make it
yes they try to make it like narrative
like a movie and um you know he was
trying to
i guess evoke a sort of
um because there's a lot of stuff in
there too that was kind of an eraserhead
because you know david lynch has always
had kind of like a um
obsession i guess sort of with
industrial machinery especially like the
noise that it makes
and there's a lot of that in here so and
there's like um a couple of characters
like anthony hopkins who plays a surgeon
uh dr treves and he you know says a few
things about like all all these machines
and they're going to be causing all of
these accidents because he's working on
a guy whose [ __ ] chest is all [ __ ]
up because he got caught in a machine or
something and he's talking about how
machines are um you know going to be the
not necessarily the death of us but it's
just kind of like they can't be reasoned
with so
there's he's almost making a parallel
between
the industrial revolution the way it
introduced like dehumanization um you
know alienation in the way that uh the
elephant man was alienated from his
fellow man because of his appearance so
they're kind so he's kind of drawing a
parallel between those two things
another thing that i thought was really
powerful about this movie the way they
filmed it and being in black and white
it
i would as as a kid
watching this
i would always lose track of the fact
that this wasn't the real elephant man
and that's the mark of a good that was
right i kept having to remind myself
that that dude is not the real elephant
man right
that that man which i hurt is fantastic
yes even though you wouldn't recognize
them you wouldn't know that was john
hurt under all that makeup and like the
voice and everything when you're young
it's easier to confuse you about when
this thing was filmed and when these
actors lived and it's almost kind of
like this is a film of of him
i can't i kept forgetting that that's
not really him that's a dude that's an
actor in a costume yeah but it looks
you see photographs of the way john
merrick really looked in real life it's
real close
well it doesn't matter if the any
difference is it's just not doesn't
matter well you buy it the makeup that
they did
um was the guy that did the makeup he
actually used the actual molds because
they had molds of the actual of the
elephant man i've seen photographs of it
yeah like in yeah they did have some
photographs of him but they did molds of
his uh skull and his face and his body
and stuff like that and they're in like
you know private medical collections and
stuff like that in london so they had
that to work from so they made molds
from that so the prosthetics and stuff
that they put on john hurt are actually
pretty accurate to what he actually
looked like you're seeing what the
elephant man looks like it's
[ __ ] horrid
terrible i mean that poor [ __ ] guy
holy crap
i don't there there's nobody i don't
think there's anybody in the at least
not in the western world that looks like
that today and do you know you know
what's weird about his disease
i was looking up on the wikipedia page
there must be people because they never
cured that disease so they must still be
out there they're not entirely sure what
that was okay um he was actually born
because i looked up like the actual guy
joseph merrick who was very famous uh
you know he was in freak shows and stuff
just like they show in the movie um they
they're not entirely sure what the
disease was he actually looked pretty
normal until he was about five years old
and then his uh he started getting like
his head started getting bigger one of
his arms started getting bigger and it's
like you can see his skeleton now too
like they have a skeleton in a private
collection a lot of that is bone that's
not just skin like his bones
were like growing like almost like out
of control
um
and his head was so big and it actually
got bigger he died when he was 27
actually um but his head just kept
getting bigger and bigger like
throughout his entire life and it comes
up in the movie and this is true also
that he had to sleep
sitting up like with his head on his
knees because he couldn't lay down
because it would break his neck
or he would asphyxiate he's living as
just like this [ __ ] hideously
grotesque
twisted image of a human being
in one of history's most [ __ ] brutal
times man
that would be he was like the worst of
all worlds for that dude i mean it was
just to look like that outside in the
victorian era
yeah in that area
[ __ ]
man that [ __ ] would have been rough man
because you were judged up by your
appearance back then
yeah and i mean they treated that dude
like [ __ ]
yeah and very very poor and one of the
things that they go into in the movie
they don't go a lot into his um into his
early life because the movie is actually
based on uh you know the doctor
frederick treves uh wrote a memoir where
he talked about his friendship with uh
with joseph merrick who was actually
called john merrick in the movie there's
um kind of there was a confusion about
what his first name was because he had a
brother named john that died and there
was all this other kind of stuff that
went on but um
but so because it's because the movie is
mostly based on dr trev's memoirs it
doesn't really go a lot into um you know
joseph merrick's early life where like i
said he looked normal till he's five and
then when he was a teenager and started
looking kind of uh freaky he actually
sort of sort of he tried to get jobs but
obviously no one would get him give him
jobs because not only did he look
alarming but he also had chronic
bronchitis which they go into in the
movie also um and his lips were so large
that when he talked um you know a lot of
people couldn't understand what he was
saying so he couldn't get jobs and
obviously back then they didn't really
if you were disabled they didn't they
were just basically like tough [ __ ] yeah
you're throwing on the ship um so he
basically was the only thing you could
do yeah he had jobs at a time but like i
said he kept getting fired because
nobody can understand him talking it's
like he had he had fallen as a kid and
broken a hip so it's kind of like he
couldn't walk he was kind of lame in one
uh
one of his hands was he rolled cigars
for a while but um one of his hands was
so deformed that he couldn't do it
anymore so he lived on the street for a
long time and then he kind of uh gave
himself to a freak show because there
was really wasn't anything else that he
could do now ironically what happened
and they kind of go into this at the
beginning of the movie too
is that he was in a freak show and he
i don't know like in the movie it looks
like he was like treated really badly
like the guy that was his owner quote
unquote mr bites um you know beat him up
and just like kept him in a cage and
just like treat him like an animal
because he thought he was an idiot
because he wouldn't talk and stuff um i
don't know
he was probably abused uh in real life
as well but like i said he did kind of
sign on to the freak show because he
didn't really have any other choice
but
um so you know so
there's kind of a thing in the movie
where
[Music]
so he's in this freak show but even at
this time in the victorian era even
though we think of the victorian era ooh
they're all into freak shows and they
want to go see all these like horrifying
things but at this point in the in
england at least uh freak shows were
actually on the way out because people
were starting to think hey this isn't
cool that we're like exploiting you know
these people and stuff like that so it
was actually kind of coming to an end
and in the movie they show
that
people were coming to the freak shows
but the elephant man was just like up
beyond the pale that was like too far
and so the cops were coming like
shutting [ __ ] down and that actually did
happen in real life um you know joseph
merrick was on display like in the back
of this shop you know and his you know
owner would pay that you'd pay to come
in and look at him and then you'd pay to
buy his little autobiographical uh you
know booklet or whatever and they
actually made okay money but it was
getting to a point where
um nobody really wanted to look at it
because they thought it was like
exploitative or they thought that he was
too horrifying um you know so they
didn't really want to do it so cops were
like shutting down the worst of them
um so at that point that's kind of what
was going on and then it so happened
that dr treves um
in real life
was at the hot london hospital like
across the street and he happened to
hear about him so he went over there and
he kind of took pity on him and kind of
you know made him
into like a medical specimen and that's
kind of like something that
they go into in the movie is that
anthony hopkins who's [ __ ] great in
this by the way um i mean john hurt is
amazing um but anthony hopkins is great
too as the doctor one thing that they go
into a lot in this movie is that
when the doctor takes him in and he
takes him in because you know he feels
bad for him obviously because he's being
treated horribly and he doesn't want all
these like people gawking at him
but then he takes him in and he kind of
displays him for his medical colleagues
um and then he sort of once he finds out
that uh john merrick as he's called in
the movie is actually quite articulate
and is actually a lovely person
um
you know when he's not being treated
like crap
and they give him like a room and
everything and they actually introduce
him to london society and ever because
everyone's really curious about him
and dr treves at one point like
questions himself like am i just putting
him in another kind of freak show it's
just now that there's a different class
of people coming to gawk at him
is that any better yeah so it's like
that's something that they kind of go
because he feels bad he's like am i
doing the same thing that his shitty
owner yeah was doing and it's like you
know you could say that but
honestly once you know anthony hopkins
character
takes him over it's like you know yes
he's still putting him on display yes
people are still
seeing him like an object to a point and
not as a person because of what he looks
like
but at least he's being treated better
than he was like at least he has you
know a bed and he has like people that
come and visit him and talk to him and
they give him like actual nice clothes
and you know the doc paper models and
stuff yeah yeah he starts building like
a model of a cathedral so at least he's
like happier
um so you could say it's kind of sad
because that's i think that's what
is so [ __ ] ultimately so sad about
this movie it's not just that
you know the people that treat him
shitty because even once he gets taken
in
and he gets a room at the london
hospital he gets treated a lot better
and you know high society people are
coming to visit him and stuff
um you still have the one guy
who is like a night porter and he's
still like bringing in like you know
low-class people like he's still
charging money and then at some point he
even kidnaps him and like takes him like
back to europe and he's not taking care
of him anymore because he just sees him
as like he doesn't see him as a human he
just sees him as like a commodity a
commodity that he can make some money
off of it's like ooh look how horrifying
the guy is and everything like that so
it's like there's still people
exploiting him um but you could argue
and and i kind of like that it goes into
that a little bit that anthony hopkins
is like questioning am i exploiting him
too like just like the carnival guy did
um you know because i'm also kind of
putting him on display or i'm
introducing him to people and it's like
almost kind of like they're not seeing
him as a human either but i think it was
definitely like a big
big difference it definitely was um
they cared about it they were treating
him as a human being and really that was
the high point of merrick's life
he was getting his very short life sadly
he didn't have to hide his face he could
wear a suit and go out in public people
were people were
toasting him and stuff but they weren't
you know laughing at him or anything you
know they but he was kind of a minor
celebrity
which now he was living the life but he
the thing is
you could never live the life looking
the way that dude which that's what i
that's what's so [ __ ] sad about the
story and about this movie too because
that movie the movie does kind of show
that yeah that it's like he was never
going to be able to have a normal life
and it was so sad because that's like
all he wanted yeah and it kind of leaves
it at the end it's kind of you don't
know whether or not he committed suicide
in a way or was it an accident you don't
know i think he totally did i mean in
real life they weren't sure
um
in the movie they portray it as
you know he went to the theater he'd
never been
and um he was befriended by like quite a
famous stage actress at the time who's
played by ann bancroft who's that's
that's actually a real person she's
playing a real person a real actor a
real actress that befriended him at the
time um and she like invites him to the
theater he comes to the theater and it's
the first time that he's ever seen it
and he just thinks it's the most amazing
thing ever
and uh at the end like she comes out and
she dedicates you know the show to him
and everybody gives him a standing
ovation and he stands up in the box and
it's almost like he's like accepted for
the first time
and then he goes back to his room
um and he's talking to uh dr trevos
anthony hopkins and he's talking about
how it was you know it was so magical it
was the most wonderful thing you've ever
seen and he's finished his cathedral
model that he was building of st
phillips cathedral which you can see
from his window and at that point he
very deliberately takes all the pillows
off his bed which he's he'd been
sleeping sitting up like i said because
his head was too big for him to lay down
and they had brought up in the movie
several times he had this little print
of a little bait a little a little kid
like sleeping in bed and he's even told
dr treves at one point i wish i could
just for one day i wish i could sleep
like a normal person uh instead of just
sitting up and so in the movie they make
it he's very very well aware that you
know he he's
well i'm pretty sure he's aware that
he's dying anyway because he does have
like a pulmonary uh disease and so i i'm
pretty sure that anthopagus tells look
you're not gonna live much longer
anyways so it's kind of like
he he knows that his life is not going
to get any better past that point so he
wants to go out on a high point
i guess because he had just been to the
theater and it was wonderful and he just
had the best night ever everybody was
like looking at him with admiration
everybody gave him a standing ovation no
and was laughing at him no one was
beating him up um you know no one was
gawking at him and so he thought well
that was the high point and i'm out yeah
um so i think that he did a [ __ ]
choke you up man
god
so [ __ ] sad this movie is so sad i
only get choked up when i get super
happy in a way
but you i don't really get choked up
when i'm sad but it's when i get
weird happiness well [ __ ] some dudes
would like that
and what it is is it's
you'll get that way watching this movie
because yeah he dies but in a way it's
kind of like a triumph
from his point of view yeah it's not
going to get any better
his time is short anyway
like i said in real life he died when he
was 27 yeah and
he's freeing himself
from a a body that was a [ __ ] prison
and you know because there's no way you
could escape that ever that's what's so
sad he was he he was [ __ ]
in real bad shape
it was [ __ ] with his mind
he was
it was amazing that he was as sane as he
was
that she would deserve and like i said
by all accounts he was a lovely
lovely person like a lovely human being
right he finally got
some good experiences and [ __ ]
society accepted him he was gonna die
anyway so he decided i'm out
that he was gonna go out with dignity
like a man which is all he ever wanted
because nobody ever looked at him like
that so in a way it was like a sad
triumph
yeah
which is kind of the way i read it but
like i said it's man it's a hard movie
to watch i was i was watching a couple
others it's a masterpiece though it is
god it's so [ __ ] good and just
re-watching it for this review i was
like god i forgot how [ __ ] amazing i
believe he was i don't i believe all
lynch's movies are masterpieces
i'm a fan of the ones that i like i got
want to see lost highway again i got to
be in a different mindset for it
it would that was good i could tell it
was good
it i i kept getting thrown out of it
though
i haven't had other [ __ ] going on you
got to be in the right mindset to watch
well for a david lynch movie you really
gotta sit and watch that yeah it's a
film it's yeah
and he's gonna [ __ ] show you a puzzle
he's so you're gonna have to figure this
[ __ ] out like i said and i said this in
my lost highway review i don't think
it's so much a puzzle it's just that he
doesn't make a distinction between
objective reality or the objective
reality of the film and a subjective
interpretation of one of the characters
that's all dude like me with my tastes
though that's a puzzle
like i said wait where do you see inland
empire
yeah you two tell me they can't
that's the lynchiest yeah
[Laughter]
that's some crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] that's a
crazy movie this movie is the least
lynchian i would no other than maybe
dune
he won't put his name on that
uh well because it wasn't it wasn't what
he wanted but like certain cuts he does
some cuts he has his name on other cuts
he doesn't have his name on and i've
seen some crazy ass cuts out there with
alan smith what they call allen's alan
smith alan smith that's the name you put
on it when you don't want your name on
it
and then some i think i think they were
kind of like fan edits based on because
there's a bunch of [ __ ] dune material
out there
and there's some [ __ ] wild ass cuts
of that movie that i do like although
the the lynch
the lynch [ __ ] theatrical release is
probably the most
you know movie-ish
i'm talking about yeah i mean
of all lynch's stuff i'm not gonna say
this is his most quote unquote normal
movie that would probably be the
straight story uh because that's a
pretty normal movie uh but this is
probably his second most normal movie
like i said it does have some lynchian
and particularly you can tell that this
came out not too long after eraserhead
because it does have particularly the
beginning where there's like a dream
sequence
of
how this uh obviously isn't what really
happened
but this is was the spiel they gave at
the carnival that the reason that uh
joseph merrick or john merrick looked
like that was because his mother was
frightened by an elephant in utero
because that was like very big and
victorian air like if the mom was scared
by something like that's what the baby
would pop out looking like so and
honestly um he believed that like his
whole life too obviously that's not
really what happened but um he believed
that that's what had happened to him
that his mom had been frightened by an
elephant so they so they kind of have a
dream sequence at the beginning of his
mom being like knocked down by an
elephant and she's like freaking and
screaming and stuff so they show that a
couple times so that's very lynchian
like i said the sound design the uh
almost like fetishization of like
industrial like machinery like the sound
of machinery and like the the site of
machinery and like workers like pushing
stuff like very industrial that's very
eraserhead so that's very lynchian but
other than that it's a pretty
straightforward but like i said it's
really cool because it's like a timeless
black and white it it seems like an old
hollywood type movie but not quite like
as stagey
um you know what i mean yeah that's a
technical way of putting it for for
average joe i'm gonna break it down to
the average meat head it's [ __ ] it's
a very watchable movie it will pull you
in okay
it it's emotional okay
you gotta be in the right frame of mind
because it's super super sad yeah yeah
partially it's a sad triumph in a
certain way about a [ __ ] very twisted
guy who's [ __ ] very handicapped
and he does have some
successes later on or or
but they're little successes they're a
big deal to him though
yeah and you can feel for the dude it's
showing you a [ __ ]
another reality it's a reality you are
very
happy that you weren't born in that
reality that really is that's really the
watching the movie again i kind of like
that was one of the big takeaways like
man that's the takeaway of this movie
all the shitty stuff that happens in
your life at least you didn't look like
that poor dude right and his health
problems
you know yeah because it wasn't just how
he looked he had like a lot of health
problems and and he was born in an era
that was very ruthless
people forget how ruthless
the in the industrial side of the
[ __ ] of the victorian era yeah it was
that [ __ ] can i have some more bread
sir yeah like i said he couldn't get a
job because he was handicapped but they
were like oh well yeah live on the
street people
yeah and people were mean
yeah and they would just spit on him and
kick him and [ __ ] like that
they didn't think they just thought of
him as like an animal yeah they didn't
think of him as a person
as you looked and
man seeing it when you're young [ __ ]
it kind of gets that into you early like
you know hey you know people can't
control how they look
yeah just like or at least for medical
stuff just back off them man god damn it
to a certain extent you can't control
how you look just ask [ __ ] dudes or
[ __ ] bodybuilders well to that extent
but it's like there's obviously genetic
factors and disease factors that you
can't [ __ ] control and they could
happen to anybody
god you know what one of the saddest
lines in this is it's before um because
for a while like even after dr treves
like takes john merrick in
um he like john merrick is afraid to
talk so because he's been with the
carnival for so long and he's been
beaten up so everyone just assumes that
he's an imbecile
because he won't talk because he's
afraid to and so for a long time like dr
trees thinks he's an imbecile too and he
says to john gielgud who's like the head
of london hospital he's kind of like um
he's like yeah he doesn't talk i think
he's an idiot and he's like
i see he said i pray to god that he's an
idiot yeah so that he doesn't know right
but then later on they find out that
he's actually not an idiot he's actually
like very very articulate and very
intelligent and real sensitive quite
well read and like i said a very gentle
like lovely person even though he's been
treated just abominably like through his
entire life so if you haven't seen them
flick man i recommend it but like i said
it's very sad and honestly yeah but
here's the thing some people won't watch
a sad movie
so you can't and i don't think it's
it has a lot of elements but everyone
should see it yeah it's kind of like the
movie that you should see it's brilliant
it is very enjoyable the experience
because it's taking you to see
what possibilities has something that
did happen to a dude yeah because there
is an out really what that dude looks
like yeah and [ __ ]
and yeah it wasn't good for him he did
he was kind of eventually saved though
so like i said it did have an element of
triumph to it yeah i mean it was saved
by good people and death i mean that's
not necessarily that was to the only
option for this dude yeah
and that's well that's what's sad right
because it's like he never really had
much of a chance no he was going to die
anyway and honestly it's good that like
you said that dr trev's you know took
pity on him essentially and you know
took him in and so he had a better life
than he would have had otherwise and he
went out in his best day
i mean i was going to say too like one
of the best
other than that scene like that scene
where he said i pray to god that he's an
idiot um the one scene like before
because they don't actually show him for
the first 10-15 minutes of the movie um
you just see other people's like
horrified reactions to him and you just
see him in silhouette and stuff and the
scene
where
uh anthony hopkins first sees him and
like i said they don't show him really
they just kind of show him in shadow
yeah but all they show is that close-up
of anthony hopkins faces and it's just
his shocked face and you should see this
one tear that's what i'm saying that's
so great the way it shot is [ __ ]
awesome so great and uh these makeup
effects are great
yeah you know what's crazy okay so this
was nominated for eight oscars
uh it didn't win any of them because
raging bull won all of them which that
was good movie that was a good that's a
brilliant movie too so i can't be too
bad also black and white uh yeah was it
i think it was wouldn't it oh gosh i
haven't seen it and so i don't think
that was black and white but i can't
remember maybe it wasn't i for some
reason i thought that was in black but
you know what's crazy about this is that
there was so there was such a big outcry
that nobody got an award for the makeup
in this
that uh because this was before the
academy had a category for that that the
very next year they added a special
effects makeup category just because
everybody had that's happened
to the elephant man no because it was
too late actually they gave it to uh
american werewolf in london which was
81.
um but yeah but that's why they added
that category because everybody had a
fit they're like why did nobody get an
award for anything like for this big it
got like a bunch of it got a bafta like
which is like the british
british oscars i think it got best
picture at that and i think john hurt
got best actor but it was nominated for
a [ __ ] ton of oscars it just didn't win
any because raging bull came out that
same year which like i said i can't be
too mad because raging bull is also
brilliant but
but that's the reason why and the makeup
effects in this are amazing the
cinematography is beautiful it's just
it's such a [ __ ] classic and like i
said even if you don't like lynch's
surrealist
thing now the surreal levels at the
correct this is not yes this is a pretty
straightforward the only surreal
elements really are kind of just like
dream sequence type stuff yes
like you said some of those shots like
them zooming in on the horrified faces
and stuff it has a little bit of that in
it that that but it's
i would think that a person that doesn't
know lynch wouldn't know wouldn't you
wouldn't notice it wouldn't notice it
you wouldn't just have an emotions taken
over you like oh [ __ ] this is a [ __ ]
masterpiece this movie it's really
interesting the way it's a must-see if
you haven't seen it you got it i mean
it's a [ __ ] classic like i said even
if you don't like lynch's other stuff
like if you don't have patience for the
surrealism or anything i can understand
it because sometimes i like that yeah
but not but this is this is a very very
straightforward uh story there's just a
couple like lynching elements and you
wouldn't it's if you didn't know
anything about david lynch you wouldn't
know it's got a lot of sadness in it but
it's because a bunch of brutal [ __ ]
happens and you're like feeling bad for
this dude but it does pick up and it and
and
humanity is kind of redeemed in it and
in the end he kind of
he he he he [ __ ] goes out like i said
with dignity and [ __ ] yeah it is it is
[ __ ] emotional you go oh man but you
in a way i'm kind of happy for him that
at least
good [ __ ] did happen that's all he
wanted was to be seen as a human being
right and he went out on a high note and
uh
he was
and
on the bright side he freed himself from
a [ __ ] horrible prison
that's the prison of that body
and there was nothing anybody could have
done about it not in that world
no well even nowadays i don't think i
don't even think they know what that was
and i don't even know if they can cure
that nowaday nowadays they never would
have [ __ ]
beat on that dude and treated him like
garbage the way they did back in the
victorian era people would know oh he
can't control that that's just a disease
yeah you know i mean people would still
stare and gawk and [ __ ] like that if he
went out probably in normal society no
you're like oh [ __ ] but back in those
days right but like yeah they would just
kick you in the street and no one would
do anything yeah he can't kept himself
covered up with a [ __ ] hole with one
for one eye getting chased with mob like
by a mob
yeah yeah and like i said spitting on
him
yeah and like i said nobody would think
anything of that because they would just
think oh you're that that's not a person
yeah you know
yeah yeah well that's why well why do
you think that line from this is so is
so famous where he still had the bag
over his head and like the mob comes
after him like in the train station yeah
and they corner him and he should they
tear the bag off his head and look at
him and he he just has to plead with
them he's like i'm not an animal i'm a
human being yeah and it's just kind of
well that's why that's famous it's like
the fact that he had to
plead for his humanity just like for
people to like look past it you know
what yeah because back then people kind
of sucked not everybody did because
obviously some people like befriended
him once they found out that he was like
you know a cool guy
and he wasn't just like a monster the
mob was very dangerous though it still
is dangerous today but it's just it was
a different element back then man i saw
something too that analyzed they said
this is kind of an interesting movie
because it seemed like most of the bad
not all of them but most of the bad guy
characters were
working class yeah the poor people uh
and you know most of the good guys were
upper class not all of them because like
i said there there was the doctors and
their doctors
yeah and there was like something
because when they first brought him to
the london hospital um there was
something that's like look he's
incurable so we need the beds for people
that can be helped so he can't stay here
but it was actually uh the intervention
of queen victoria of all people um and
her uh
her daughter-in-law who came in and said
you know oh we love what you're doing
here with the poor and you know and
people that are deformed and stuff it's
like keep that up so that was pretty
much they said we'll give you a stipend
so he can stay there like for the rest
of his life it was it's
it's still kind of true today and
anywhere in the world been [ __ ] the
ghettos [ __ ] rough you know it's very
physical you got to fight to survive
poverty and [ __ ] like that
and [ __ ] merrick
was
he couldn't even make it in the ghetto
he was below ghetto he was [ __ ]
gutter yeah gutter get it you know so
and like i said he tried to work he went
to like work houses and stuff like that
but he couldn't because of his
deformities like he couldn't do a lot of
stuff
his salvation in this case and that's
the way it really was
in victorian england at the time you
know and this is how it went down with
merrick
the rich educated people saved him
because he was that [ __ ] pitiful and
it's not to say that the rich and
educated were like
the good guys
all the time in in in victorian society
a lot of them were [ __ ]
yeah users
were gangsters you know sure really but
uh good people who had means saved him
and that's saying something because
that's how bad it was for him yeah this
is in an era where they were [ __ ]
homeless children running around [ __ ]
turning tricks that was just they just
did that okay yeah you just had to like
i said there were no there wasn't like a
social safety net or anything like that
or not much of one
the insane asylums maybe yeah they would
just and then they would just like
change that was like a prison they'd
chain you to a wall yeah you know and
you just like lay there and they'd throw
gruel at you like once or twice a day
yeah and you just had to [ __ ] where you
were and right i mean just horrifying
where do you think the word bedlam came
from yeah not to pick on england [ __ ]
at that time england was the leader of
the world it was worse than other
countries yeah that's right yeah it was
bad there but it was worse than other
crowds
the only thing better
if you were [ __ ] destitute
than that would be escape to america and
[ __ ] head towards the [ __ ] west
that's where all those [ __ ] cowboys
and [ __ ] were coming from they're
running for matt
yeah because it's like that wasn't great
either but it was better than what they
clean living sleeping outside yeah at
least you can just camp out and camping
out it was cleaner yeah cleaner fresh
water
you know yeah but
i mean
just just watching this and like i said
they did he did take some artistic
license with the story but it's not that
far off uh what actually happened
um so just watching this just makes me
like appreciate and not only is it a
beautiful
a beautiful looking movie the acting's
amazing it's just a great like like you
said it's just so emotionally
uh just
devastating i guess but and emotionally
involving too but it also really makes
you appreciate
not only how good it is to live in
modern society
but
how you just making you count your
blessings that you weren't born
yeah like that yeah you know and it's
also a good thing to say
about
humans and human society and british
society
the people that had the ability to help
him eventually did yeah people did help
him not everybody sucked i mean a lot of
people did suck and treated him horribly
or tried to just exploit him for money
because he looked like that you know
they wanted him to display him in a
freakshow they didn't care about his
health or anything but there were good
people that actually did care about him
in real extreme cases they'd help a
[ __ ] but
if you were just a little bit deformed
too bad yeah yeah but in extreme cases
they could help you in a way yeah in a
way that might have been because he was
so so bad so bad um you know he kind of
got the attention of even the queen
well yeah well because like i said there
were freak shows all over the place and
they let a lot of the freak shows go on
but the reason that his usually got shut
down was because he was too monstrous
um they thought that that was like too
much yeah uh you know so that's that's
kind of what i could from that scene
yeah because like a lot of his [ __ ] got
shut down like in real life like his his
displays and everything
hey man see the movie see elephant man
it's it's a required view it's on yeah
it's on amazon prime right now if you
have amazon prime also if you don't have
amazon prime it's also on pluto.tv for
if you're young feeling sorry for your
[ __ ] sorry ass self ah see the
elephant man yeah if you're like feeling
kind of ugly one day yeah no see the
hell with it man go wide and then go
look at pictures of the real guy because
yeah then shut the [ __ ] up and then shut
the [ __ ] up yeah because seriously
they did take pictures of the real guy
they like i said they molded the makeup
in the movie on the reel on molds of the
real guy dupe is [ __ ] up and yeah
there's only one person that it comes
close and has seen a photograph and i
don't know the person's name i don't
know if it was male or female
it's a picture of a person an adult
person who was born with syphilis they
were in the womb and the mother had
syphilis and they caught syphilis while
they were in the womb
when you
their entire life attacked by this virus
since an infant and when they're fully
grown they look just like eddie from
iron maiden on those iron maiden album
covers the early like from the killer's
album cover that's what it looked like
yeah
yeah like a living corpse
oh
scary yeah you could probably google
that photograph person genetics is no
joke man this isn't [ __ ] up [ __ ] can
happen so yeah and this [ __ ]
that virus got into that person's jeans
and just [ __ ] him up
and there's a black and white
portrait of that person and it's just oh
man it'll make your [ __ ] skin crawl
you cannot believe that that's a living
person
yeah like i said you can't imagine
you're a living corpse i mean none of us
can imagine what it must be like like
living in a in a body like that because
like i said you can't control it you
can't hide it you can't escape from it
um that's like i said that to me that's
the saddest thing about this movie yep
but yeah so go watch it like i said it's
on amazon prime for free if you have
amazon prime or it's on pluto.tv free
with ads uh you can watch it on there as
well or you can run it on youtube uh you
can run it on there for 2.99 i think but
yeah it's a [ __ ] masterpiece it's a
classic um even if you don't like david
lynch totally watch it it's an amazing
amazing film so uh that'll do it for
this movie retrospective we will see you
guys on the next one
bye
you